welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and disney plus has confirmed a
nick fury series is in the pipeline
starring samuel l jackson in a post
avengers in game mcu that is more or
less confirmed to be
agent of sword an offshoot of agents of
shield with ties to one division
spider-man far from home captain marvel
2
and leading up i believe to an avengers
secret invasion event
who needs movies like black widow and a
mere title announcement can connect the
dots in such a way to spell out the word
hope
no no you don't clint barton don't deny
my hope giving mission
seriously folks i'm gonna break down all
the easter eggs we've been given to this
nick fury agents of swords series
explain what we learned coming out of
agents of shield because i know not
enough of y'all watched it
and lay out why this fury series is
going to be so important to the mcu's
future
coming as soon as mid-2022 okay so the
reports for this nick fury disney plus
series come in the wake of fury's most
recent appearance in spider-man far from
home when the post-credits scene
revealed his role throughout that film
to be a disguise
by the skrull shapeshifter we met in
captain marvel talos with maria hill a
disguised by the squirrel shorin
the real nick fury we learned was
chilling on a skrull space station
looking for his shoes
at the time we identified this space
station as the peak the headquarters of
sword
sentient world observation and response
department an interplanetary defense
offshoot from
shield in the comics the ongoing
partnership between fury and the skrulls
tells us that the alliance forum to
captain marvel never really ended and
in fact evolved this station is likely
an upgraded replacement of the hidden
cloak space station where the squirrels
were hiding maroon in the early 90s
the pager that he and carol danvers
exchanged to captain marvel which
chronologically later returned in the
avengers infinity war post-credits scene
when he tried to summon her was later
revealed to contain
an engraving on the back of it for sword
and sword it looks like
is the government agency in the upcoming
wandavision series
apparently running a security perimeter
around scarlet witch's pocket reality
the sentient world they're observing and
responding to there is the one coming
from her mind and among sword are the
astrophysicists darcy lewis from the
thor movies
jimmy wu from ant-man and the wasp and
monica rambo growing up from the girl in
captain marvel
last seen with taylor's squirrel
daughter you guys have the best eyes
don't ever change your eyes that
louisiana farmhouse moment was the
origin of
sword nick fury's secret contingency
agency which the mcu thankfully now has
since you know shield was corrupted by
hydra
interestingly sword's existence was
alluded to all the way back in iron man
2 by justin hammer though i doubt he was
aware of it anthony stark has created a
sword with untold possibilities
and yet he insists it's a shield many
also believe that finale of agents of
shield set the stage for sword though
it's technically not confirmed to be mcu
cannon spoiler warning for agents of
shield
the alternate timeline mid lane of that
final season left the world of agents of
shield with mack as a nick fury-esque
figure running shield from the deck to
helicarrier
coulson flying past a version of
washington dc with the triskelion still
intact in the background
and daisy cor and susa in space
approaching a space station now you
could read this as all going down in an
alternate reality of the marvel
multiverse or an implication that the
episodic storytelling of the agents of
shield
is now headed to the stars with agents
of sword but
it is not confirmed if any of these
agents of shield cast members will
appear in this fury disney plus series
honestly at this point i wouldn't be
surprised if kevin feige titled the show
agents of sword pretending agents of
shield never happened but the most
important implication of this fury
series announcement is what it tells us
about the now
likeliest upcoming marvel crossover
event avengers
secret invasion but before i continue
thank you to our friends at
bang energy for sponsoring this video
[Music]
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it is sugar-free and it has zero
calories
yet it tastes great
with over 20 different flavors to choose
from one of those great flavors is
in the name bankster berry no not the
lame
basic berries that grow on bushes but
bankster berries that are
banged in your mouth look it's sweet and
it's fruity and it gives you energy
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea or keto coffee
flavors
you can also get clothing or fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video
get 25 off at bang energy.com using the
code newrockstars25
so with a nick fury agents of sword
series on disney plus marvel is now
perfectly set up to pull the trigger on
an avengers secret invasion event
in the comics secret invasion revealed a
ton of faces we know and love
as skrull imposters it kicks off when
elektra
dies and she reverts to a scroll form
shortly after this a coordinated scroll
strike occurs we find out that hank pym
is also a scroll he attacks reed
richards and then
squirrel dub dub dugan triggers the
explosion of the peak space
station squirrel edwin jarvis activates
a nano virus that corrupts tony stark's
armor
and all of earth's satellite defenses
and in the amazing ensuing melee pretty
much
all of the avengers and a number of
celebrities and political figures get
assumed at some point by scroll
imposters now you might be asking if
in the mcu the skrull are friendly with
nick fury and the people of earth
why would they antagonistically invade
human society as they do in the comics
well i believe that in the mcu that
invasion
hasn't been done with evil intentions
but to protect us
planting these extraterrestrials
throughout human society assimilating
into our culture all to better defend us
from the real threat
the imperialistic cree empire
this way marvel could reveal a number of
well-known figures as i made the case on
in a number of videos
maria hill sharon carter howard stark
rudy as scrolls
secretly working to help us from the
very beginning the whole time
past mcu easter eggs have revealed an
ongoing cree
threat there is that throwaway line and
far from home revealing one of sword's
priorities in the mcu
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top-secret information nick
that tells us that fury and the skrull
and sword are
currently in the midst of a covert war
with the cree
with the cree having their own sleeper
cells to undermine earth's interests
the way the u.s and the ussr had sleeper
cells set up across each other's borders
during the cold war so it's looking
likely that this fury series on disney
plus will feature this
cree skrull shadow war on earth now
protected by this sword organization
imagine the americans on fx but instead
of matthew race and carrie russell
working under margot martindale as
russian spy seeking to undermine the fbi
you're gonna get nick fury and his
scroll agents secretly protecting earth
from the onslaught of the cree
and considering the ties with the first
captain marvel film it wouldn't surprise
me if this release was being timed with
the release of captain marvel 2
still scheduled for july 2022 so
assuming the fury series can get
production wrapped by the end of 2021
we could see a release early summer 2022
to coincide with captain marvel 2 but
the end game of that chapter the
narrative i believe will be
decrees ultimate power move to screw
over fury
sword and the scroll they're kind of
thanos snap moment
leaking the truth to all of humanity
that not only do skrull exist on earth
but that many authorities within their
ranks people they know
are secretly skrull shifters and so it
wouldn't matter if the scrolls are
helpers imagine what infowars j jonah
jameson is gonna do with that bombshell
us terrans don't want your help greedies
c-53
wants to be c-53 from this secret
invasion your technocracy
is dead on arrival and as these
triggered and suspicious humans make the
first strike against their actually
friendly shape-shifter friends
the mcu will descend into the next major
crossover event
avengers secret invasion but i believe
key to fury's involvement with sword
will be a partnership with a new
character abigail brand
commander of sword in the comics excited
to see who they'd cast for her
and monica rambo's relationship with
taylor's daughter i'm gonna be going
more into those implications in this
week's episode of rogue theory be sure
to check it out
discuss these series with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
thank you for watching
and hey if roadie is revealed to be a
scroll that would explain that weird
moment in civil war
boom you looking for this
[Music]
you
[Music]